we've had so much Trump stuff all week
and we are going to take calls after the
break that I want to do an on Trump
story right now for you you might
remember the story of bigoted despicable
rancid anti-gay scofflaw Kentucky County
Clerk Kim Davis who refused to issue
marriage licenses to same-sex couples in
Rowan County Kentucky last year after
the Supreme Court decision banning bans
on same-sex marriage at the state level
there are four couples to same-sex
couples and two straight couples that
sued Kim Davis as a result of her
actions and she has lost her legal
battle to be a bigot and here's the
sweet sweet irony of it or justice call
it what you want Kim Davis might
actually have to pay the legal fees and
costs of her opponents which are two
hundred and thirty three thousand fifty
eight dollars ultimately the lawsuit was
resolved after the Kentucky Republican
governor changed the state law to
eliminate the need of clerks to even
authorize licenses so there was this
thing where for whatever reason the
clerk had to authorize marriage licenses
and the Kentucky Republican governor
said you know this is really kind of a
an S storm if you know what I mean let's
just change the law so that Kim Davis is
no longer even in the position of being
the decider about these marriage
licenses however as for her own costs
Davis has had a pretty easy ride that
anti LGBT liberty Counsel did the legal
work for her for free great for her but
she may actually have to pay up now
because the four couples who sued her
are appealing to US District Court Judge
David Bunning to seek an order allowing
them to recoup the 233 thousand fifty
eight dollars in legal fees and costs
now you might say we'll hold on she was
acting in her capacity as Rowan County
Clerk at the time maybe Rowan County
Clerk should pay the cost and they said
no no no no no she was directed to issue
marriage licenses and she was acting on
her own behalf and we are not going to
cover these costs now Liberty Council is
still defending her for free they're
fighting the order on the grounds that
since she didn't really lose the case
she shouldn't have to pay
the cost and that is technically true
because the lawsuit was done and then
the Republican governor said you know
what the County Clerk no longer has to
sign marriage licenses so now these
couples can go and get the marriage
licenses without Kim Davis's signature
on them and the liberty Counsel is
saying because the law was changed she
doesn't know anybody any money of course
that doesn't change the fact that at the
time of the lawsuit that wasn't the law
and legal costs were incurred by the
four plaintiffs
all she has to do pat is put up a
website and the anti-gay haters are
gonna give her money you do a little
GoFundMe campaign for hate like that
crazy anti-gay pizza restaurant next
thing you know she'll have two hundred
and thirty three thousand bucks and the
crazy part of the story is she was
almost treated like a martyr by uh
conservatives that Mike Huckabee who
would put their out there in his
campaign rallies Kim Davis is exactly
the reason why a certain contingent of
conservatives is just not taken
seriously in America she's the textbook
definition of a hypocrite she says all
traditional values biblical values she's
been married four times to three
different men cheated on husband number
one with husband number three
yet morality made it so she just
couldn't issue a license of for marriage
to a same-sex couple she won't even be
an asterisk but rather a coffee stain on
the history of LGBT rights in the United
States and it comes down to her
delusions of grandeur your job Kim isn't
to figure out whether your particular
God's morality is consistent with a
Supreme Court decision it's the hand out
marriage licenses and collect your
paycheck and after the Republican
governors decision to change the law her
job is not even any longer to hand out
marriage licenses I hope that she ends
up having to pay and to pay big little
silver lining in what's been about a
week of uh pretty bad news today on
Veterans Day I'm thinking about our
veterans and our active-duty military
and our reserve military today because
we have a president-elect now that
clearly is not a friend to veterans we
have seen that time and again I am sure
that after the break when we take your
phone calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we will
hear from callers at least some of whom
are concerned with the upcoming actions
of President to be Donald Trump glad
you're with us today